[Musica]
oggi parliamo dell'essere umano titolo
di questo ted a dx
pescara l'essere umano nasce per sua
natura imprenditore in quanto
imprenditore sappiamo che è sempre la
ricerca di nuovi progetti nuove idee
siamo affamati siamo curiosi siamo
innovatori l'evoluzione della specie ci
ha consentito di sopravvivere
adeguandoci al contesto adeguandoci al
contesto e soprattutto ci ha consentito
di trasformare tutti i problemi in
opportunità
l'uomo e sperimentatore lo sappiamo
dalla corrente elettrica
la ancora prima dalla scoperta della
ruota alla scoperta della polvere da
sparo fino ad arrivare ad oggi ad
internet
abbiamo leonardo abbiamo galileo abbiamo
adriano olivetti tutti esempi di
grandissimi innovatori
ma noi sappiamo benissimo che dietro ad
ogni ad ogni impresa di successo c'è un
uomo c'è qualcuno che ha preso una
decisione coraggiosa che ha lavorato
affaticato è caduto si è rialzato ha
sudato ha fallito e ha ricominciato
senza mai perdere la speranza di
raggiungere il proprio sogno perché il
filo conduttore di tutto è il sogno e la
passione e l'ambizione di ogni singolo
uomo sembra facile non è così l'ente
nella mente a infinite potenzialità
questo lo sappiamo ma sappiamo anche che
nella mente di ognuno di noi c'è un
fattore che viene chiamato pigrizia la
pigrizia che tutto sommato ci porta a
resistere ai tanti cambiamenti questa
pigrizia ci porta a stare nel nostro
guscio tutto sommato abbiamo questa
slide che rende perfettamente al
calduccio alla fine della nostra zona di
comfort la zona di comfort dove stiamo
bene ma chi ce lo fa fare a cambiare
chi ce lo fa fare apprendere delle
strade nuove strade dove non sappiamo
dove arriveranno quindi siamo portati
più a rimanere nel nostro percorso
abituale a di fare sempre le stesse cose
ea difendere quello che abbiamo trovato
al nostro equilibrio all'equilibrio che
ci ha portato come dire a stare bene ma
non vole a decidere di non voler
cambiare questa e l'attrito che viviamo
tutti i giorni e l'attrito su cui stiamo
studiando è l'attrito che porta
l'innovazione a spingere le persone a
cambiare ma questa forza come dire
centripeta porta le persone a rimanere
nel loro status quo volevo partire da da
un racconto da un aneddoto personale che
penso possa essere condiviso e messo a
fattor comune in questo in questo
contesto perché ho vissuto personalmente
una situazione del genere sono il terzo
di tre figli e vengono una famiglia di
professionisti
mio padre architetto noci o ingegnere
una sorella architetto avevo la strada
spianata mio futuro era disegnato nello
studio di famiglia avevo già la mia sede
al mio tavolo ai tempi non c'era l'auto
card ma c'era ancora la matita e e la
penna e quindi il mio destino era lì
nello studio di famiglia durante il
secondo all'università accade una cosa
semplicissima durante un viaggio mi
fermo in un autogrill e compro un libero
i sette pilastri del successo un titolo
anche un po così
stephen covey guru del management
americano lo leggo lo studio arriva alla
fine c'era l'indirizzo era il 1994 non
c'era internet non c'erano le e mail e
quindi scrive una lettera foglio penna e
scrive una lettera la mandola spediscono
mi rispondono e mi scrivono un primo
corso metto i soldi da parte durante
l'inverno per andare nell'estate in
california a studiare inglese a
frequentare questo primo programma di
formazione
vado un primo anno secondo anno mi
appassiono torno ancora al terzo quarto
anno di università
torno e deciso di aprire una società un
gioco segue una passione mi era venuta
come dire l'entusiasmo di seguire quello
che avevo visto e di fatto non ho fatto
altro che prendere il copiare tradurre e
trasferire nel nostro mercato
a quei tempi immaginavo che potessero
arrivare le nozioni dagli stati uniti
poi in italia ma non era ancora mi
sembrava ancora prematuro mi sembrava
ancora prematuro perché non c'era
internet fondamentalmente quindi
iniziare questo gioco seguendo questa
passione il giorno mi divertivo a fare
l'imprenditore e la notte studiavo
studiavo e facevo l'ingegnere tutto ciò
la cosa bella di tutto ciò il problema
più grande di tutto ciò era che nascosi
tutto ciò a mio padre perché mio padre
sapeva che alla fine degli studi
finalmente sarei andato a lavorare da
lui e questo non avvenne
fu più facile fare l'esame di stato
laurearmi anche con 100 su 110
fu più facile fare tutto ciò che dire a
mio padre che io non avrei seguito la
sua strada non avrei seguito questa
spinta esterna perché tutto il mondo
attorno a me mi diceva devi andare lì ma
che sei matto il posto fisso posto fisso
di checco zalone lì io avrei avuto il
mio futuro ii e decisi di non seguire
quella strada
disse a mio padre che non avrei seguito
quella strada e ancora oggi mio padre
non ha capito esattamente di che cosa mi
occupo
ma va bene così mi vede felice sa che ho
seguito la mia passione e da lì è
partita una nuova
come dire vita sintetizzo come dire
questa prima fase della mia vita in
questa formula tratta da un libro uscito
nel 1974 da pubblicato da timothy
gallwey theiner game mode tennis e
sintetizza in questa formula p di
potenzialità di performance uguale alle
potenzialità meno le interferenze
interferenze interne interferenze
se seguiamo esattamente lapillo l'ho
cancellato potenzialità ho messo
passione ho messo passione perché credo
che la passione sia la vera forza
motrice di tutto e da lì infatti una
volta avviata la prima società né
prostitute e altre parti con altra un
altro progetto un'altra ancora uno falli
e un altro ricominciato fino ad arrivare
al 2014 luglio del 2000 anno della new
economy miss insieme amici colleghi
parenti manager e imprenditori miss
falisci uffici una sorta di quotazione
in borsa chiedendo soldi a tutti ma
fondamentalmente finanziarono la mia
passione non c'era altro finanziario la
mia idea che si chiamava challenge la
mia sfida finanziarono non c'era altro
dal 2000 inizio quest'avventura
avventura che ancora oggi
oggi festeggiamo i 19 anni partì nel
2000 con una crescita costante ma lenta
ma costante fino arrivare al 2004 2005
il gruppo cresceva le persone
cominciavano a seguirmi e qualche
successo cominciamo a raccoglierlo
ma 5 danno era il 2004 2005 un milione 9
di fatturato 2 milioni 2 milioni e 100
milioni al 9 di fatto erano fermi e io
penso che l'ambizione di un imprenditore
sia quella di veder crescere
continuamente un po come il padre con un
figlio vedere crescere continuamente la
propria creatura e le prova di tutte
provai a cambiare le persone che
lavoravano con me a formarle a cambiare
processi alla comunicazione marchi
cambiare tutto e non succedeva niente
continuiamo a rimanere fermi di fatto ci
fu un fattore esterno fattore esterno
che incise molto nella mia vita incise
positivamente e fu l'arrivo di andrea 14
giugno 2007
voi direte cosa c'entra la nascita di un
figlio anzi la nascita di un figlio
ti rimette in discussione come dire
tanti fattori fattori emotivi fattori
come di tempo anche fondamentalmente mi
rimise in ordine la scala dei valori
ero totalmente fino a quel giorno
concentrato sul lavoro
ero troppo presente in azienda ero
troppo egocentrico e perfezionista non
delegava non facevo crescere le persone
che erano attorno a me avendo meno tempo
perché volevo fare anche il papa e
volevo seguire la passione per mio
figlio
cominciai a delegare cominciare a vedere
che le persone autonomie crescevano che
l'azienda tutto sommato poteva camminare
con le gambe sewell con le gambe proprie
senza dover per forza avere la mia
presenza sul posto e quello fu una
scoperta bellissima perché mi resi conto
che cominciava a crescere a diventare
anche matura l'azienda è
fondamentalmente di l'azienda
dall'esterno fuori dal sistema
prima ero dentro il sistema e quando sei
nel sistema tante cose non le vedi avevo
cambiato scenario lo vedevo da fuori
vedendolo da fuori mi resi conto di
tantissimi fattori ma uno
fondamentalmente sul fattore
determinante ovvero avevo provato a
cambiare tutto per non cambiare niente
perché fondamentalmente non mi ero messo
in discussione io mettendomi in
discussione e cominciando a cambiare
realmente io i miei comportamenti
declina i comportamenti diversi con
tutti con tutti i collaboratori e
l'azienda partita ebbe immediatamente
uno scatto una crescita una crescita di
ogni anno 2 milioni 3 milioni 4000 e
5000 e 6 milioni stata una crescita
importantissima e possiamo dire come
vendendo una frase di einstein che non
possiamo pretendere che le cose cambino
se continuiamo a fare sempre le stesse
cose e di fatto io quello facevo
cambiavo tutto per non cambiare niente
perché non mi ero messo in gioco in
discussione io da quel giorno il focus
ancora più forte della mia attività
professionale è stato quello di aiutare
le persone e le organizzazioni a
cambiare perché di fatto
sappiamo benissimo che sono le persone
che compongono le aziende il successo di
un'azienda non è dell'azienda azienda
una scatola vuota
il successo e delle persone che
compongono l'azienda è infatti in questi
anni ci sono degli studi importantissimi
che approfondiscono l'analisi dei
cambiamenti nelle organizzazioni e uno
studio della società internazionale shl
ci dice che il 64 per cento dei
cambiamenti o dei tentati cambiamenti in
azienda fallisce solamente il 34 per
cento va a buon fine come si fa a stare
in quel 34 per cento io li voglio stare
voglio aiutare come dire anche gli altri
a stare in quel 34 per cento
come dicevo bisogna lavorare sulle
persone perché sono le persone che fanno
la differenza e fondamentalmente in un
periodo come questo dove viviamo una
grandissima trasformazione digitale c'è
una rivoluzione culturale che non è
solamente dettata da quante up quanti
strumenti digitali o quanti altri mezzi
abbiamo disposizione quelli li abbiamo e
li sappiamo anche usare bene ma
fondamentalmente prendendo spunto da un
acronimo preso in prestito dal mondo
militare che sintetizza questo periodo è
un periodo dove i punti di riferimento
che avevamo fino a qualche anno fa sono
crollati non ci sono più è un periodo
volatile un periodo in cui c'è
incertezza è un periodo in cui ci sono
molte ambiguità complessità è di fatto
l'unico fattore che può portare a un
reale cambiamento è la mente dell'uomo è
l'approccio agile a tutto ciò
l'approccio a rimettere in discussione
tutto ciò è su questo l'uomo ha infinite
potenzialità deve solo decidere di farlo
sappiamo benissimo prendendo spunto da
un proverbio antico che dice
puoi portare un cammello alla fonte ma
non puoi costringerlo a bere noi
possiamo prendere le app e gli strumenti
digitali di tutto il mondo
ma se siamo noi a non decidere di voler
cambiare non serve assolutamente a nulla
però in questo periodo siamo in un
periodo importantissimo perché perché
siamo nel periodo delle start up
io ho intitolato questo intervento siamo
tutti start upper negli ultimi cinque
anni dati istat usciti qualche settimana
fa ci dicono che negli ultimi cinque
anni sono nate 10.000 start up e tutti
sappiamo serenamente che delle startup
solamente una su 100 anzi ultimamente le
statistiche sono anche più basse però
diciamo per essere ottimisti che una su
100 avrà successo
le altre 99 falliranno falliranno le
imprese falliranno i progetti ma non le
persone
il fattore di lusso che hanno le start
up e che hanno la possibilità di fallire
senza pregiudizio noi no noi siamo nato
in un'epoca in cui era impossibile era
quasi denigratorio avere un fallimento
alle spalle fallimento inteso di
progetto non di azienda e invece oggi
abbiamo questa potenzialità
abbiamo questo lusso e non è un lusso
solo per gli imprenditori a un lusso per
tutti perché la startup non è solo per
chi ha l'idea nel mondo digitale o
tecnologico la startup oggi è il
contesto che viviamo ci permette di
provare a rivoluzionare tutto anzi
dobbiamo farlo dobbiamo farlo perché
perché oggi siamo ad un bivio
possiamo approcciarci al mondo del
cambiamento in due modi in maniera
reattiva o proattiva il reattivo e
quello che come ero io quando fingevo di
cambiare ma cambiavo tutto per non
cambiare nulla e cercavo di
resistere al cambiamento cercavo di
resistere e fingevo di provare a
cambiare e lo facevo con la paura di
cambiare e non lo facevo con l'obiettivo
reale di portare dei cambiamenti quindi
avevano approccio totalmente reattivo
era il mondo esterno che mi diceva devi
cambiare ma in fondo in fondo non volevo
il proattivo e quello che invece decide
di voler cambiare è il primo che si
mette in discussione mette in
discussione tutto quello che attorno a
sé oggi noi possiamo partire dalla
reattività per arrivare all'approvazione
e arrivare poi ai cambiamenti un ultimo
aneddoto volevo raccontarvi che mi vede
di nuovo parto dalle cose come dire
apparentemente negative
sto raccontando gli approcci come dire
quasi più sbagliati che ho avuto perché
da lì ho capito in maniera reattiva dove
poter costruire in molti mi dicevano è
una bella azienda in italia stai
lavorando molto bene ma devi andare
all'estero e io dicevo man dove vado
all'estero
sono anni che non parlo più inglese da
quando andavo negli stati uniti a
studiare ma doveva dall'estero ho
bisogno mi creava alibi mi creare o un
contesto che mi permette a di ma tutto
sommato sto nel mio nella mia area di
confort qui in italia tanto bene
parlo un po milanese un po romano un po
torino un po bologna ho parato tutti i
dialetti ma fondamentalmente non avevo
deciso di cambiare fino a che un giorno
mi dissero un primo cliente un secondo
un terzo ministro noi andiamo all'estero
ci stiamo trasferendo io da domani vado
a lavorare a dubai dopo domani vado in
spagna quindi o ti organizzi e ci segui
oppure continuerai a perdere i clienti
quella è stata una spinta reattiva io
non sono andato all'estero perché una
mattina mi sono svegliato deciso a che
figo faccio l'imprenditore all'estero no
ho seguito degli enti per paura di
perderli e da lì dalla prima esperienza
reattiva poi ho cominciato un viaggio
che oggi mi porta a muovere i primi
passi alcuni progetti alcune startup
l'abbiamo avviate e sono fallite
abbiamo aperto una sede
a teheran nei periodi di obama e oggi
ovviamente ferma
abbiamo aperto a dubai che sta andando
molto bene abbiamo aperto in serbia che
galleggia siamo in spagna sono i piccoli
passi stiamo cominciando ad andare
all'estero non è detto che andrà tutto
bene non lo sapremo ma intanto abbiamo
alzato la testa ma sono arrivato a
questo grazie alla reattività e la
spinta esterna che mi ha portato a
questo aspetto prendendo uno spunto non
da un guru ma del management ma un muro
del cinema woody allen che ci dice se di
tanto in tanto non hai degli insuccessi
significa che non stai davvero innovando
e chiudo con un ultimo aspetto l'ultimo
come dire importante aspetto che ha
segnato sta segnando positivamente la
mia vita 4 gennaio 2018
arriva lorenzo secondo piccolo questo ci
aiuta
mi ha aiutato mi ha dato una spinta
importantissima della quale ancora non
saprò gli effetti gli effetti come dire
sul business sulla vita personale
precedendo li so a questo punto gli
effetti veli per raccontare tra qualche
anno al prossimo the dx
grazie
[Applauso]